Have you ever noticed, after studying English
for a while, that you don’t learn as many
new words as you used to?
Don’t worry, that’s completely normal,
and there are ways to overcome this hurdle.
Let’s take a look at three ways you can
continue to improve and grow your vocabulary.
First of all, what’s the point if you’re
not having fun?
Are there any particular subjects you're interested
in?
Do you have any hobbies?
You could learn new words by doing some research
online and reading about it.
If you don’t like reading, try listening
to songs and looking up the lyrics or watching
a movie you like with the subtitles.
You could also try word game apps to help
you with new words.
The important thing here is to have fun.
Don’t you hate it when you discover a new
word and you forget it when you want to use it?
One way to help you remember the new words
is to keep a word journal.
This can be on your phone or a notebook if
you prefer.
To help you remember, write down the meaning,
pronunciation and an example sentence that
makes sense to you.
If you use a dictionary app, you could add
a link or post a picture of the meaning
next to it.
As the saying goes, use it or lose it!
Once you learn a new word, make sure you use
it, so that you can remember it better.
The best way would be to use the new word
while speaking.
If you don’t have anyone to talk in English
with, don’t worry: you can still use the
new word in writing somewhere.
It could be in a social media post or a personal
journal.
And, as mentioned before, you could play word
games using various apps and try to use it
then.
Remember, use it or lose it!